and Sachs Pearson with over 100 million
players on 14 platforms the Minecraft
community is one of the biggest in
gaming until now minecraft players
haven't been able to easily share and
connect with their friends unless they
were on the same platform today that all
changes thanks to the power of Xbox Live
with Xbox Live for the first time
players across iOS Android Windows 10
can easily play together online and
share the world with their friends
excited to unite our community no matter
what device they play on so we're
calling today's release the friendly
update because this is our friendliest
update ever connecting with your friends
on different devices is cool what's even
cooler dedicated servers that let you
host your own worlds and share them with
your friends so that they can play with
you even when you're not online with the
introduction of realms you can play with
your friends how you want where you want
on whatever device you want the choice
is yours
let's jump in and check it out stacks
welcome to my realm I'm playing here on
my iPad sax is on my Xbox Live friends
list so he can easily hop on straight
from his surface heading your way now
Lydia
well this pick is not gonna make it any
easier than No
there you are sax your catch a diamond
well clearly you did that just for the
achievement yep an Xbox Live achievement
on an iPad on stage at e3 okay let's
keep going it's great coming back to my
room and seeing what my friends have
built when I've been away they're always
building something new and right now
there's a bit of an obsession with
Pistons and all of this works for the
new gear via virtual Minecraft on oculus
we've got just the perfect friend here
to show us that mind if I join in please
welcome from the oculus team
john carmack john how does it feel to be
in gear vr it feels like you're living
and breathing in a Minecraft world I've
said that minecraft was my grail for VR
and this was the most important gaming
application that I could be involved
with the ability to spin around take in
everything and have the freedom to
explore an endless world is what I
thought the core of VR was intended to
be so Lydia what do you have to show me
in your realm check out we started
building all right here we go
minecart rides in VR spectacular oh that
dragon looks really awesome I think I'm
gonna stay down here this looks like a
good spot to start construction on my
mad scientist lair thanks John it's
awesome seeing all of these devices
playing together xbox live in realms are
available today and are the first step
in our journey to night minecraft
players on all platforms but before we
go we wanted to show you something else
we've been working on let's head through
this tunnel and take a look today we're
also releasing texture packs - Pocket
Edition in Windows 10 this modern
landscape was built using the city
texture back texture pack so you change
how any block or character looks in the
game we want to let players remix
anything in Minecraft and to make that
happen
we're bringing add-ons which are coming
this fall let's jump down to the rooftop
and take a look
add-ons let players change mobs and
animals into something completely new
the aliens on the rooftop used to be
zombies but we modified them and gave
them a fireball ability making them much
tougher
oh no stacks do they find their hiding
spot I'm coming over to help to balance
a fight we've changed the villages to
giving them extra style with sunglasses
and suits and we tweaked their AI so
they're brave enough to fight aliens
with us so Lydia
now that the villages are helping us
let's go over and deal with the UFO
awesome let's head to the Redstone
cannon I'll be right behind you
I'll deal with this beefed up iron golem
if you go and fire the cannon all right
ready redstone and TNT what could
possibly go wrong
nice shot
Thanks let's get out of here
we know we hope you enjoyed this early
look into how you'll be able to change
your game it's just a first step towards
a fully multiple future for Minecraft
add-ons will come to Minecraft Windows
10 iOS and Android and other mobile
additions this fall we're also working
hard to bring add-ons and realms to Xbox
and consoles next year until then
download the friendly update with realms
and Xbox Live anyone with an Xbox Live
account can sign up right now and try
realms for free on your phone tablet or
Windows 10 we have more news and new
surprises for our community at Minecon
in September thank you